- [Voiceover] I wonder if I
could just squeeze one out.
(squeaky fart)
Did Zack hear that?
Oh no, he has headphones on.
Good, I'm totally getting away with this.
Oh, no.
Oh god, it's bad.
Why did I eat that breakfast burrito?
Maybe if I look like I don't care.
You know, just working.
Nothing to see here.
Maybe if I swivel back and forth
I'll get the air circulating
and like kind of fan it away.
Okay, it's working.
The fanning works.
Now no one will ever know.
(stomach rumbling)
Oh no, not again.
(fart)
(grunting)
- Okay, who did it?
It smells like garbage in here.
Come on, just admit it.
It smells like butt.
- I know, right?
Someone's going off here.
Are you like fanning it
this way or something?
Because it's like very
concentrated like just right here.
- Gosh, that is thick.
- Very rich.
- That is some thick gas.